[Musik]
perfekte illusionen allesamt entstanden
auf dem cover von mariana milosevic
genannt kicker millionen menschen aus
der ganzen welt klicken sich zurzeit auf
die immer neuen kunstwerke der serben in
ihrer wohnung in smederevo 50 kilometer
von belgrad entfernt hat sie sich ein
kleines atelier eingerichtet
ständig produziert sie neue videos
schon als kind hat sie gern gezeichnet
die malerei hat sie sich selber
beigebracht
ihr besonderes markenzeichen sind
optische täuschungen
ich liebe herausforderungen deshalb habe
ich beschlossen mich auf optische
täuschungen zu spezialisieren
es ist einfach lustig wenn man sich ein
knoten in den bauch macht oder was auch
immer
es macht mir einfach spaß dem jeden tag
bin ich jemand anderes
erst vor gut einem jahr startete die 35
jährige ihren eigenen videokanal mit
diesem bodypainting als holzpuppe gewann
sie 2016 in serbien eine wichtige
auszeichnung in der maskenbildner szene
das war ihr internationaler durchbruch
mehr als 130.000 menschen haben ihren
youtube kanal abonniert und verfolgen
regelmäßig ihren neuen videos für sie
ein traum
ich bin so glücklich
ich habe kontakt zu menschen auf der
ganzen welt
und wenn sie mir schreiben küsse aus
brasilien oder küsse aus frankreich dann
habe ich das gefühl als wäre ich schon
dort gewesen oder als sei ich dort das
ist ein ganz besonderes gefühl
mittlerweile kann die zweifache mutter
von ihrem video kanal leben und zwar ein
neuer filme postet sie pro woche ständig
bekommt sie rückmeldungen von überall
her auch auf spanisch ist dann ist so
außergewöhnlich in dem was du machst du
überrascht mich jedes mal aufs neue
ich wünsche dir alles gute und macht
weiter so mehr als vier millionen
menschen haben alleine dieses video
angeklickt kicker kann ihren erfolg
immer noch nicht so recht passen
ich denke jedes mal was ist wenn die
leute es nicht mögen und was ist wenn
sie es nicht und wenn das video dann
hochgeladen ist dann kann ich gar nicht
hinschauen dann sage ich immer zu meinen
kollegen und freunden hätte mir bitte
nur die guten kommentare vorlesen zwei
tage bereitet sie ihre motive vor
guckt sich im spiegel an was passen
könnte und was nicht und sie findet
einen knoten im bauch passt irgendwie zu
her bis zu acht stunden arbeitet sie an
ihren jeweiligen kunstwerken inspirieren
lässt sie sich durch musik oder durch
ihre ganz eigenen erfahrungen
ich hatte ein problem mit meinem gewicht
ich konnte nicht essen ich hatte keinen
appetit und das fühlte sich für mich so
an als hätte ich einen knoten im bauch
erst mit dieser schwarzen hintergrund
wand werden die optische täuschungen
perfekt das knifflige ist für die
maskenbildnerin außerdem ständig beim
malen die luft anzuhalten
sonst verwackelt das bild und ein
bisschen zauberei ist auch immer mit im
spiel
hokuspokus und ich habe einen knoten im
bauch
doch die illusion künstlerinnen zaubert
nicht nur knoten in ihrem bauch sondern
auch andere formen wie diese spirale
sie gehört zu dem holzpuppen
bodypainting und war für kika die größte
herausforderung diese spirale hat mir so
viele probleme bereitet denn es ist irre
schwer auf dem bauch zu malen auf der
haut des bauches
denn du darf sich nicht bewegen wenn du
am ende ein perfektes bild haben
möchtest mit ihren perfekten körper
gemälden verfolgt kicker ein ganz großes
ziel
[Musik]
mein traum ist es eines tages auf dem
roten teppich zu stehen und den osk
einer hand zu halten
bevor es soweit ist produziert sie aber
noch weiterhin make-up kunstwerke und
tutorials für ihre fans
immerhin auch us schauspieler charlie
sheen hat schon eines ihrer videos
geteilt
vielleicht schafft kicker es hier am
ende mit ihrer kunst ein bisschen über
sich hinaus zu wachsen und dabei nicht
den kopf zu verlieren
[Musik]